this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] thank
you for checking into the joint the
joint is brought to you by relief band
listen you know your uncle joey has
anxiety i talk about all of god damn
time
that's why relief ban helps me with my
anxiety you know it's the real deal
relief ban has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and prevent anxiety
induced nausea and vomiting do you deal
with nausea from motion sickness hey so
do i
morning sickness chemotherapy relief ban
helps with that also it's like the name
says it's just a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea
caused by things like anxiety you change
the intensely depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker
let me tell you something when i had my
surgery relief band put me together
i wore this thing everything guess what
i'm gonna start worrying again just you
know i got to travel and stuff the next
couple weeks i'm going to be on a plane
so relief band is 100 drug free
non-drowsy and provides a natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects as long as needed and they just
released their newest model relief band
sport the sport is waterproof has an
extended battery life and can even
attach to your apple or android watch
who's better than relief bad nobody
listen i know you got a grandmother
grandfather and uncle maybe they're
doing chemo maybe a child like for me i
gotta get one for mercy because emotion
sickness in the car this is the way to
go relief ben makes a great gift for any
time of the year and right now they got
exclusive offer for the joint listeners
if you go
to
reliefband.com and use promo code joey
j-o-e-y you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee
that's relief ban and that's the best
offer you'll find anywhere but you still
got to use my code so head over to
relief relief band.com r e l i e
f b n d dot com and use promo code joey
for twenty percent off plus free
shipping listen relief band you're not
gonna be sorry the joint is also brought
to you by my favorite cbd lion
listen i've been with them for years you
guys know this every week you hear me
talking about it and for me this is the
best cbd out there
from the gummies to the kinesiology tape
you know what my knee was bothering me
yesterday i put some kinesiology tape on
it last night and when i went to the gym
today i'll tell you what i didn't even
feel it that's how great
their cbd is so do yourself a favor if
you're looking for capsules the tincture
is tremendous the gummy bears with the
melatonin the cream cbd line is for you
go to cbdline.com
and read read up on the third party lab
results also on the benefits of cbd
cby and cbn before you go to liquor
store and ask some swami from salami you
might as well go to cbd lion and throw
down with uncle joey so go to
cbdline.com
order something throw in ko joey joint
or church and get 20 off delivered to
your house
that cbd lion now without further ado
let's get this party started it's
wednesday morning [__]
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
thank you
for [__] uh clicking on youtube and
watching uncle joey's
joint on wednesday february the
[__] 16th a beautiful [__]
day to be alive it's been cold as [__]
here in jersey lately that wind is on
jack and i'm the type [__] when
i come home at six
like i usually leave my [__] key in
the car to see if i'm going out
[__] no in this cold weather i come home
i click that [__] car click click you
ain't gonna see me till the next goddamn
morning it's cold at night and i love
cold weather don't get me wrong i don't
disintegrate it's not
that bad but man
you got to get [__] used to it great
weekend great week so far you know i got
a couple things going on
uh i got a little surprise for you
[__] at the end of the week
you're gonna be all [__] excited but
for right now i wanted to talk about the
soup bowl soup bowl was great i had a
great [__] time i went over to
jimmy's and it's funny because
i'm having a little [__] uh
i never really had a mid
life crisis you know you know everybody
you're going to get a middle life crisis
you dump your wife you [__] some hot
asian chick you get a corvette
ah
please
my midlife crisis my midlife crisis
right now is what i'm having like i went
to jimmy's [__] great food
you know sausage and peppers pizzas i
mean it was tremendous
and uh
i bet the winning side you know uncle
joey i love cincinnati all we getting
the [__] four and a half four that's
a field goal they gave it to you you
know what i'm saying you just got to
read the [__] line it was funny
because
a couple weeks ago i was at my
daughter's uh kickboxing school fat
joe's great [__] place and i was
talking to one of the dads a [__]
solid dude this dude's built like a
[__]
door i went to his house one time to eat
he's [__] huge canadian dude i love
him and his wife and their kids
but he's a smart [__] like he's
off the rail smart like
analyst econ [__] you know
you could tell when you talk to him he's
very heady like he's very heady in his
thought
and uh we were talking he goes who do
you like i goes i love the rams
let me talk to you about something do
you think you're just going to march in
there
the rams are going to win by 20 at home
on the lord's day and that's it the
bookies are going to take a beating it's
the number one gambling day of the
[__] year
plain and simple everybody bets on the
super bowl grandmas
chinese people [__] everybody bets on
the super bowl okay it's just it's just
that big of a [__] day and there's
nothing to counterbalance it
so if there like was a big ufc mcgregor
or somebody
the super bowl could say okay we'll
we'll lose the game but we'll get our
money back on mcgregor but that's not
the [__] case there was nothing to
count to balance it and there's just so
much [__] dough getting launched on
it that you got to take it the bookies
cleaned up this weekend you never seen a
bookie with a part-time job that's my
all-time [__] favorite saying because
i love people who think they're going to
gamble and beat the system you're gonna
win
if you're thinking about how many people
make a living off gambling it's a small
percentage if you think it's tough to
[__] be a comic
try being a [__] professional gambler
because that there's ups and downs
and when you're up you're up you gotta
know how to load up and when you're down
when you're not picking you gotta know
how to [__] pull back and watch from
the sidelines and get some [__]
momentum it's it's tough gambling it's
very tough i
love it not the degree of uh you know
betting millions of denial
entertainment
entertainment is a big difference in
being a [__] gavon all across the
board so anyway back to [__] tarzan
at fat joe so we were talking and he's
like now the rams like it's not going to
be that easy
trust me you know
and i said in fact they're going to
shock people
and i didn't know listen to rams on
paper
were way better than [__] uh
cincinnati but again
they're not gonna they didn't get to the
super bowl because they're gonna [__]
suck dick so
i like cincinnati i like the [__]
under i bet the under all the the things
i lost were the props i lost every
[__] problem the kiss of death but i
had the right side and the right total
and that's all that matters but it's so
weird how
i looked at football season this year
just to learn i just wanted to do an
experiment you know and i got to be
honest with you i did really well pick
wise for football
and i could see early on the season i
made some mistakes with some totals and
whatnot
but
i did really well with football my
sports to gamble on a [__] football
ufc everything else i suck dick on i
don't even take a chance i don't like
card games basketball once in a [__]
while but it's so
you know the ball goes out of bounds
they hit a free throw you lost your ass
so and basketball's every day so it
you're going to go down a hole
eventually and i don't want to see you
go down a hole i like the occasional
football bet maybe a college football
bet on a saturday i don't bet college
football
but it's funny after the game came in i
was talking to my wife and i go you know
i'm really good at this [__]
it's so weird i just don't have balls to
bet the farm i have a daughter i have a
wife when you have a child you just
can't go that's their money you know
what i'm saying so
uh
but it my wife and i were told she's
like like last week you were over at the
murders around the corner and you were
talking about football and you were
winning that night you know she goes why
did you learn this and i go
from losing
that's how you learn to win you don't
learn to win from [__] you know you
learn to win by losing by paying a
bookmaker by paying draftkings and
you're like i don't need to pay this
[__] 25 draftkings got 50 of my
[__] dollars this week what the [__]
is going on here you know what i'm
saying so
over the years like i gambled
straight to the time i left
uh north bergen in 83 i [__] gambled
and after that i really
never did it again
until i just moved back here every once
in a while when i went to vegas with
rogan
me and ari would put a betting on the
ufc but as far as
doing it every night i didn't have a
bookie back there i don't know anybody
in that way so gambling's been out of my
life you know so i was telling my wife
that
you learned i learned by having
the [__] sixes when they were in
their heyday against the nets at the
[__] meadowlands and the sixers were
given four i didn't see it i lost my ass
i had to go [__] mug somebody to come
up with money for the bookmaker when i
robbed the jewelry store you know i had
to [__] lose inside because i didn't
know how to read lines it's not dog if
you're looking at percentages when you
gamble if you're looking at oh
their defense isn't listen you're doing
the wrong thing because moms
grandmas are betting [__] football
and winning meanwhile you're sitting
there like johnny [__] mnemonic going
through charts and [__] so that's what
i'm saying he was too heady it's like
joe rogan i love joe rogan to death but
he's very hard for him to pick a winner
in the ufc because he's so heady he's so
intelligent me i'm just looking at the
[__] line that's all i'm looking at
so
it was really weird i learned this at a
young age you know not with
my mother's sports none of that [__] i
had no idea what was going on
i learned how to gamble an 80 [__]
three and i learned the benefits of
gambling and the decline of gambling and
that's when i made my decision
[__] uh february of 83 i made a
decision
never to gamble again it was between
gambling and snorting coke i'll take
behind what's door number two because i
figured i realized that when i gambled i
got nothing for my money
you sit there you [__] sweat bullets
you curse you say racial slurs you know
whatever the [__] you're yelling at the
bar
and next thing you know you go home and
you got rabbities you got your [__]
pockets like empty you got nothing you
know what at that point in 83 when i was
20 i made a decision that [__] i'd
rather look out a window and crawl on
the floor looking for a coke rock at
least i'm doing something i'm burning
calories then [__] sitting there
watching somebody else [__] scoring
you know you can't control gambling and
in my mind i felt like
i need fifty thousand i'm gonna put
fifty thousand on somebody and that's
what i used to do that's not not fifty
thousand i'm exaggerating but i'd bet
five grand
two grand you know how much money i had
in my pocket when i made those bets two
dollars
and i'm like [__] if i lose i come up
with the money on friday jesus christ
that's a horrible way to live
but in 83
after i robbed a jewelry store in 82 the
40th anniversary coming up in september
i hid out for a while in sarasota
florida and then i came back to jersey a
little dude named ferny what i've been
thinking about a lot lately
i miss him
uh you know like i said the other day
it's 40 years since high school
when i moved here in the back of my mind
on my someday me conti
ferny and [__] peleo get together
pelly ended up dying
ferny won't return my facebook messages
and i talked to glenn in fact i talked
to glenn this morning so
but i learned a lot from his
demise
ferny hit rock bottom in 83
and i saw him you know i saw the whole
thing go down
it was no bueno
and uh
we started getting like when i came back
from sarasota i had a little bit of
[__]
gold chain money left
so i got a job right away
fernie's father got me a job at this
warehouse
that set up these [__] cabinets for
enterman's donuts when you walk into a
store a supermarket and you see those
shells that say anthem and donuts
we would make the display it was a it
was a place in edgewater new jersey it
was a union job
you worked seven to three
and [__]
i think i did it for like a month and we
got fired
but it was tremendous because i had i
was hustling
you know i was doing whatever the [__] i
was doing and then
i got the job it was but fernie's
father's restaurant was called hmb diner
on edgewater road down there and [__]
this was
um around the corner you know in fact if
you ever watch copland that liquor store
i used to go there for one of the guys
every day it was a little skinny black
dude he used to give me a couple dollars
to go get him blackberry brandy every
day for lunch tremendous when you're 20
this shit's [__] tremendous right so
every morning we wake up freeze our
[__] ass so i still remember being in
this car
shivering
you know october of 82
and [__] like vanity was on you know
uh
tuning in and
nasty girl that jam i still remember
being in the car me
stinky ferny freezing our [__] asses
off at 4 45 in the morning
and listening to nevada that's how
[__] crystal clear like i told you
[__] i don't know what happened
two days ago but 30 years ago i'm on it
i'll tell you sentences
speeches the whole [__] thing so
we would go to every [__] day five
days a week and then we had a tab at
ferny's father's restaurant we just go
in there and get pork sandwiches at
three dollars a piece there was weeks i
only met like 20 bucks from all the food
i ate at fernies his father was a
tremendous cook
but we would get to this place
and we already like we the guy who got
us fernie's father got us the job
through this dude
and we went to the dude and go listen
we're out all night drinking
if you think we're gonna live [__] he
goes listen i don't mind just go up to
the attic
and hide you know what i'm saying we
would go up there and [__] hide all
day me and this cat stinky would go up
there and [__]
you know play football we'd line the
boxes up because they had big
refrigerator boxes and we lined the
[__] boxes up like linemen and [__]
and i'd get a football out of the car
and i'd run around the lineman he'd
tackle me that's what we did for [__]
seven hours we went to lunch at fernie's
we got high we brought a bottle back for
the skinny black dude and that was it we
reported to the skinny black dude i'm
sorry i don't know what his name was if
we were 20 he was maybe 50 this [__]
dude and he drank every day he wore
gloves with
little [__] zits off his fingers and
[__]
good guy you know i i love the guy we
were there with him and he wouldn't
[__] report us or anything but one
day the reason why we got fired
everything was going great
and the only job they'd make us do me
and stinky was when the uh
was to take
the boxes for the
refrigerators and
hand them
they're these huge boxes so you got to
turn around pick it up and hand it down
it was from the second floor
to like two floors down it was a big
piece let's say the piece of
cardboard was eight feet long kind of
heavy
so we're [__] doing all this and with
one of them i started working really
fast
and i just said glenn move back
and i would just whip him to him
we did this every day
we go up there [__] play some
football eat a pork sandwich then come
back and whip those things either whip
them to me and then i put them on a
pallet or i'd whip them to him
well this particular day we're up there
and we're [__] whipping them
and the little skinny dude the black
dude our boss comes over and he's like
hey
you got to double up on these because we
got somebody picking them up i i don't
know what the story was i i wouldn't
i'm going to blow smoke up your ass huh
he goes in fact i'll help you now he was
a skinny dude he was always drunk you
know he always had three or four shots
and he smoked dope
and you know me i'd feed him dope every
day i'd give him the best dope and tell
him to smoke a half a joint and he go
what the [__] is that [__] dog you
[__] almost killed me this went
on
so this one day he goes you and glenn go
up on top
and shoot us the boards down
and me and i'll get another dude like a
chubby white dude and we'll [__] load
glenn will shoot to him and you shoot to
me okay
so i'm [__] up there this is
you and i'm you know i'm a young kid i'm
[__] zipping him
and he's like hey man slow down you know
what i'm saying what's the matter with
your brother this is a union job take
your [__] time because it's a
union job what are you in a rush for
they're going to pay the same [__] so
he starts moving back right because we
were loading them so fast
and all of a sudden i threw one and i
saw the wind kind of caught it
and he's like man slow down with those
things
and on the next one i didn't mean to do
anything from the bottom of my heart i
like this dude i took the board and i
just went and he was a little farther
away
and the thing caught some air and it was
like a flying carpet and you could see
his face like he lost it and [__] like
he he thought he had it but he lost in
the sunlight and [__] and all of a
sudden the thing just went it curved and
just went
i seen the [__] from the top i
saw the thing curved like a magic carpet
then it just zoomed right in and hit him
right in the bridge of the [__] nose
boom like three inches of [__]
cardboard moving 40 miles an hour this
dude goes down like a bad habit he goes
out jack he's bleeding from the bridge
of his nose he's got a little contusion
on the back of his head from falling
backwards and [__] tremendous
and you know we got them up we cleaned
them up but the boss is like listen you
guys just come here to [__] around every
day i can't have it you're done so you
fire this
i went and got a job at [__] uh
this
fairview uh
hardware store right
great place nice family
but in the meantime i'm living with
fernie
and i'm going out at night maybe three
nights a week ferny had to be at work at
six in the morning so he wouldn't go out
during the week so i would just tell him
the next night when i seen him what we
did the night before
so
one night he does come out like on a
tuesday night and he's listening to me
and stinky talk and pele and
mcneil and he's listening to us talk
about gambling
and he pulls me aside and he goes what
the [__] are you guys talking about all
the time
let me go gambling you know we're
talking about basketball this now all of
us were losers
trust me i'm telling you this losers
with a big l tattooed on our foreheads
we couldn't pick a winner
and he's like man i i think i want to
gamble you know i want to gamble what
you do so i'm like okay you know we'll
find you a good game you know we'll find
something for you and i'll teach you
now at the time he was a cook but he
also was a waiter
at his dad's restaurant so he would take
his tips
and put him in a box
under his bed
he wouldn't even count him he'd just
throw a box in there
so
it's a sunday and
it's like december
we had done some quaaludes and [__] went
to see pat benatar
the guy at the meadowland store we were
handicapped he put us in the handicapped
side tremendous
so
the next day we wake up
[__] he goes i want to put in a bet
who should i bet i don't know funny you
you know football as much as i do you
know
he bets a thousand dollar parlay
he goes under his bed takes out the cash
counts it puts all the singles and tens
and fives together and he thinks he'll
like 1600 goes [__] it i'm betting a
thousand dollar [__] parley
oh my god who do you like we called with
a friend's dad pelley's dead god rest
his soul
and the next thing you know it was like
seattle versus pittsburgh and some other
team well he better to team pilot the
first game was like the one o'clock game
he won
the second game was like seattle
pittsburgh not you could look it up i
don't know who what it was it was
december of 82.
pittsburgh opened up a 28 27 nothing
lead
and i actually put because i wanted to
support him i actually put like 10 a 10
time paul and which is uh
70 to lose and 160 to win if i'm correct
who the [__] knows it's been years since
i did all that [__]
so [__] uh i put in like 10 times of
them
once the one game won and the team we
bet for the four o'clock game was losing
i guess we were both hungover and we
[__] and fell asleep
this [__] wakes me up and he
goes dog they this is what it was
they were losing
28 nothing and whatever came back 29
28 he had a dream that they came back
and won he woke up and they came back
and won he woke me up
he goes we won we won i go i
he goes i don't even know how much i won
and we put the bedroom with my friend's
dad
so he called my friend's dad my friend's
dad like jesus christ your best the
first bet you ever put in you put in a
thousand-time parlay and the
[__] comes in how lucky are you
so we actually go down in a sunday night
pick up the cash i don't know what it
was guys ten thousand whatever with two
[__] stupid kids
he wants to go eat a lobster tail he
never ate lobster take him up to
picalissimo
he drinks the finger bowl i mean
tremendous we had a great night
that was the opening night of his
gambling career
if that was the opening night he
couldn't in his mind think of what it
would be like
three months down the road like i saw
him already like
guys i was a novice all sort of gambling
the only person i saw loser as a
gambling was my mother
so i wasn't too you know i didn't know i
didn't know the [__] whatever
freddie kept betting
fernie kept [__] betting big big and
guess what guys
winning
i don't know how the [__] he was doing
he was betting totals
and a game he would bet like three moves
and they'd go three you know
this went on for about four or five
[__] weeks he kicked ass and the nfl
[__] playoffs i mean it was just
amazing how much money he had
one night we're talking the super bowl's
coming up it's miami against
[__]
uh the redskins with john riggins and uh
miami dolphins with the killer bees two
great [__] teams
i think uh washington was favored
i loved washington i [__] loved
washington riggins was tough
the offensive line was the hogs it was a
great [__] team
at this time i wasn't doing bad i was
working
i was hustling a little bit
i knew i was leaving
so i was planning things to leave
i had my eye on this bookmaker in west
new york that i wanted to rob that was
my big [__] you know i hear you like
i hope that job calls me back my big
thing was i can't wait to rob this
bookmaker [__] embarrassing
embarrassingly think about it
so that bookmaker was going to be my
cash out
something bad was going to happen i
would have to leave town i robbed the
bookmaker
boom and i go
so
super sunday comes fernie says to me
listen man i went under my bed
i got sixty thousand dollars in cash
from the bookie
i go what are you gonna do cause i'm
gonna bet it all in miami i go what
i guess i'm gonna bet on miami i'm
putting miami and over and all this [__]
and then the phone started ringing
and this [__] started sitting on
bets
and so did i
i was sitting on bets too
for some reason they couldn't put bets
in
so i sat in a couple you know small bets
i'm not a [__] [__] ferny sat on big
bets
one thing leads to another
guess what the the [__] dolphins get
killed
i'll never forget sitting there in the
room with him we lived in a basement
apartment we had two open up beds
the bathroom smelled like a sewer that's
where i ate the [__]
that's when i that's the place where i
lived when we mugged the janitor and i
gave him the epileptic pills and [__]
it was just a nightmare it was a cute
little apartment it was great
but i still remember sitting there with
fernie and in the back of my mind i won
like 800 bucks
fernie lost
plus he sat on 20 000 worth of bets
18 years old guys
i i didn't know what to do i felt
[__] terrible
i really did i you know i felt guilty in
a way
i didn't make him pull the trigger you
know what i'm saying he asked me about
gambling he asked my friend about
gambling we told him and he started
betting [__] big
i mean he never really recovered from
that after the super bowl he must have
slept for a [__] week
and uh
the next day morning i wake up fernie
won't get out of bed
i feel terrible for him
i go pick up the 800 i [__] won plus
i had about 400 in my kick from sitting
on bets
i go to a charlie's like a big shot it's
[__] freezing it's like a day like
today [__] freezing the sun's out
beautiful [__] day
and i uh
go eat a nice breakfast like a big shot
that i am you know what i'm saying i won
[__] some money
and i go [__] it i'm gonna go into this
city
so i take a bus into the city
i take a train that's what i did i took
uh i took uh
the george washington bridge
and i took the a train down to about
160. i forgot how [__] cold it was
i walked down to amsterdam and i'm down
there walking the [__] around
and i used to go to a particular place a
health food store
it was a skinny black dude you walked in
there he had bulletproof glass there was
a you who two use
and maybe tiger milk
protein bars like maybe two tiger milk
protein bars that was a health food
store back then in the [__]
in the [__] 80s
so i went in there and i told the guy
listen you know what he got he goes i
got the buddha i got the sense i got
everything that in those days the buddha
was big buddha chocolate thai
buddha chocolate buddha regular buddha
there was a thousand buddhas going
around harlem and they were all [__]
good and basically it was a weed called
lamb's bread
which a lot of you guys it's gone now
you might have to go to miami to get it
maybe jamaica i'm not sure people
duplicate it in la we got lamb's bread
that ain't lamb's bread [__] that's
[__] squank that's not a lamb's bread
so
i [__] go over there it's freezing
out
and i'll never [__] forget that
i tell the dude i i think i don't know
what he charged me i bought like eight
dollars worth of wheat
in those days that was a lot for uncle
joey i only had money to buy 20. but i
had just one i bought like [__] 80 90
i forget what the [__] it was
good weed and i look at him like look do
you mind if i roll a [__] number in
here he goes nah god you're a good
customer i go it's too cold out there to
roll i remember the tv on in there and i
wrote the [__] number i walked
outside and the wind off of amsterdam
was just blonde the wind would come off
the [__] huts in there and you're
dying it's cold as it is it's like
[__] 18 degrees
i'm like okay
i couldn't even like the [__] joint
i was trying to light the joint i'm in
corners i'm in alleys i couldn't light
the joints so i walked in and there's
like a little thing where you you know
those new york city apartment buildings
have like those little alleys like a
superintendent walks through there to
take the garbage out and [__] i went
into one of those things but i had my
back facing the street
and when i went in the corner like and
cut the [__] thing
i'm trying to roll it i feel a [__]
gun to my head guys
and i'm like what the [__] and he goes
put the weed down
put the lighter down
put your hands up behind your neck
and he goes new york city police
identified himself
i put my hands behind my neck he [__]
handcuffed me
i go what's going on he goes uh were you
smoking pot i go yeah yeah it's right
down on the [__] floor
he goes listen man there's a school down
the block i'm gonna go in your pocket if
you got more than [__] like 10
singles on you i'm gonna break your
[__] head i was like oh no what are
you talking about i live in jersey
because no no he went in my pocket he
reached out there was nothing but ben
franklin's in that thank god he goes
where'd you get this money i told him i
had the redskins yesterday
he goes listen get on your hands and
knees like not on my hands he goes get
on your knees and keep your head
behind your head until the van comes
and i go am i arrested
and he goes let me see
uh you have a license on you and right
away i'm like no
now usually when somebody a cop in those
days asked me if i had a license on me
or id i would say no and they'd ask me a
name
i'd tell them a [__] up name just you
know to whatever
guy turns me around he goes what's your
name
i have no idea what's your name joey
diaz jose diaz
date of birth i give it to him
he goes all right sit down until the
[__] van comes i'm like what [__]
van
i'm gonna get arrested the day after the
[__] super bowl
god damn it now i had just gotten
arrested a couple weeks earlier
for [__] trying to push some checks
and [__]
oh my god damn i gotta get [__]
pinched on the the day after the super
bowl plus i got money
the van pulls up he carries me to the
van he takes the [__] cups off he
sits me in the van
it's like a fort dude patty van with a
with a whole [__] control center in
there i never ever seen anything like
this so i [__]
sit there and he goes what's your name
again write it down i wrote my name down
my address
and for some reason i wrote the [__]
truth i had just gotten busted
uh on the jersey side this is new york
city
he goes let me get your fingers and it's
like it was just like a
a fingerprint thing
i put my fingers down i think i had to
put my whole hand down and within
[__] 10 minutes
my id came up and he goes all right jose
dear bye bye goes alright you told me
the truth because he asked me did you
tell me the truth i go yeah why would i
lie goes i'm going to run you i thought
he was going to run me on the [__]
phone or the
walkie-talkie you know jose diaz when
they run jose diaz it's always a crap
shoot because i don't know what's gonna
[__] come back
so he comes back and goes oh you got
arrested in jersey a few weeks ago yeah
he goes all right this is the story
there's a guy selling weed
to kids and we're getting complaints so
when we shook you down
it was for the [__] for sales
obviously you're not selling wheat
you're just a consumer you came over
here to cop a bag of wheat absolutely
okay what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
write you a ticket he took my [__]
bag of weed and he took like half it out
and threw it on the floor
then he rolled the rest up and put it in
my pocket that's pretty [__] cool
he goes i gotta do that because then
like i'm telling the truth for the
weight
he only charged me like two grams or
something i i don't
i don't [__] remember he gave me a
ticket and uh
i went five one i
you know i went to the weed store and
got another [__] eight i had cash
checked
i [__] took the cash and i [__]
went home the reason you're like joey
but you didn't tell me
how you learn how to read lines what's
that got to do with you reading lines if
you [__] got arrested for reefer ah i
was getting to that [__]
so now
remember i got that ticket they gave me
a ticket
so when i went home a couple days later
i had to call a number and they gave me
a court dick
okay now it's college [__]
basketball season so the super bowl
ended this is july 31st 1982.
the super bowl was on the 30th how do i
remember i don't [__] know so now
you know february comes you know it's
new york city you're not gonna go to
court the following week you're gonna go
to court in like eight weeks and sure
enough when do you think my [__]
court date was
march madness the [__] finals the
night of the finals i had to go to court
it monday night at six o'clock the game
starts at seven check it out it was
houston against north carolina [__]
state
okay now this is the second time i had
done this with a line
the line started i don't know
i don't remember the line on this game
but it was very high
13 points or something
the day of the game it went down to 11
which made a guy like me go bananas
when the line goes down two points or a
point that means they're pushing you to
bet on that team go against that team
they know some you don't know
me i'm an [__] me and all my buddies
bet
big on [__] five slam pajama houston
with a keem the dream clyde drexel the
whole [__] thing
the other team was you know valvano's
[__] thing you know don't give up the
whole thing the cancer coach whatever
good [__] guy great coach
i can't believe mike chaszewski's
retiring after this year but anyway
what's that got to do with hr with you
authority on [__] coaches now listen
no i just like basketball
so [__] uh sure enough i bet big on
this
stupid [__] college basketball game
as soon as the line went down to 11
i loaded up like 300 bucks guys
i'd have 300 dollars
i didn't have [__] 300 dollars
so
i'll never forget being in court and
waiting to go up
in front of the [__] judge the judge
you ever go to night court guys in new
york city you're going to be there for a
few hours all right
it's a large representation there at
night so i kept going out to call sports
phone
every time the [__] judge took a
break i went out to call a sports phone
and doug they were losing out right
never mind giving 11 points like they
were winning by eight and they still had
to cover they were losing by [__] 15
so i know i was a gun the moral of the
story is
when the line shifts the other way
don't bet that team
bet the [__] underdog
friday nights okay any friday night when
i was a kid
the celtics with larry bird and the
sixers of julia serving
if they were home they would always give
a big line 12 13 14 but
at game time the line would go up two or
three points
that's
that means
bet the farm
if you're given 14 and the line goes up
to 16 that means they want you to bet
the underdog that's when you that's when
your dick gets hard and you bet it all
you're gonna see
if you do it ten times eight out of ten
you're gonna [__] win
and those are line movements
the biggest line i ever lost was san
diego against the raiders on a monday
night game i think the game ended up in
81 the game ended up
on a 56 to 60 [__] score
i had the over yeah it was too [__]
easy it was uh air corielle against
[__] the raiders or whatever the [__]
it was
but here was the thing on that game
the line went from seven and a half
to seven
me and my buddies were at hash rays all
day counting the money
we bet [__] san diego the raiders
[__] clobbered them so it's not about
the totals
it's not about how many rushing yards
it's not about the [__] quarterback
it's not about i could tell you one prop
everybody lost with
this weekend odell beckham
right whatever odb the odell beckham jr
used to be a giant everybody bet him to
[__] score right two three [__]
touchdowns and he got hurt i think he
scored one i'm not sure i don't remember
who gives a frenchman's [__] i'm not a
statistician
but all this [__]
i love these type of podcasts when i
could just rap to you [__]
about life
you know we gotta get a good giggle and
then you go smoke some reef and go on to
your bad self
but all those [__] things though i
lost those games listen you remember
some people remember their wins
like my biggest payday when i was a kid
was joe montana against the dallas
cowboys san francisco the
dwight clark you know i still remember
arguing that night with people how
dallas was going into san francisco
giving them a point and san francisco
ended up winning by [__] one
so all these things every time you lose
money like i always tell people
you want to learn a lesson lose money
anybody can [__] learn a stupid
lesson but if you really want to learn a
lesson lose money that lesson will go
with you for the rest of your [__]
life that's how that [__] works out
and that's it now for the rest of the
[__] year i mean i don't even think
that we have draft kings it goes into
march mad it's amazing how much gambling
tapers off after football
it tapers off close to
to 48
people just go [__] black people just
go dark they don't want to bet nothing
else they don't like basketball
baseball's too [__] hard you got to
give a run it's a weird world guys
but if you're looking to be a
professional gambler first off hit leah
and see how that [__] works out
and always remember the house you know
the [__] sides are against you all
the time the house is against you all
the time this is gonna be the hardest
you got a better chance of making it as
a comedian
than being a [__] professional
gambler so that's why
when i when draftkings came to me and i
went on there and [__] around that
page i wasn't too
into having a gambling
sponsor but
after i saw how you had to pay them
like i thought like
i thought that if you gave them like a
card like an american express card and
your limit well you don't have a limit
with american express
they would give you like a limit and
then every month they would deduct it no
no no no
every bet you put in gets knocked off
your [__] card they won't do a
[__] card they won't do a paypal it's
crazy all i could use is my atm card
that's it but i've only made two [__]
deposits three [__] deposits two
two so everything else i just lived off
and like i said i enjoyed doing the 25
bets i'm not when i said in the
beginning i was a gambler no i'm not not
like
most people in the stories i wasn't no
marky wahlberg
i wasn't no [__] james khan in the
gamble the great movie i could never
turn into one of those things and after
what i saw my mother do with [__]
gambling
[__]
that
gambling is an entertainment vehicle
that's it if you're planning on getting
limos and [__] and cocaine
you're in no danger when i worked for
the sports betting service they wanted
you to portray a guy that lived like
that like my alias
was pete patella
when pete patella would call you he just
got back from vegas
he was hanging out with the [__]
guarichi brothers
eating steaks he just dropped off
antonio brown over at yay's house
you know
you know what i'm saying
it was that character because you want
to sell people
the [__] notion that they could
become you they want to be you you're
not selling them the games
you're not selling them gambling you're
selling them you you know what i did
last night mother what'd you do last
night you stayed home in your mother's
basement you know what i did last night
i took a choice i didn't know what i
wanted to drive my lamborghini on my
corvette on my helicopter i went over to
my little asian girl's house i snorted
some coke off a [__] we ate some wontons
and then i went to vegas eight one
eighty thousand dollars and came home
when you talk to somebody like really
i'm gonna be like you it's [__] scary
it's scary so if you're gambling and
you're thinking of being a big shot it's
not gonna happen but if you like that's
it for me
i gotta know like golden state's gotta
play now golden state lost last night
i'm [__] believable two nights ago to
the clippers that's how you know things
are [__] bad
the clip is that's alonzo bowden's team
but anyway i'm sorry i'm talking about
[__] sports and i just i didn't talk
much about the suit ball on monday and i
felt bad a couple of people hit me up
and said joey you didn't talk to us
about the super you know guys when it
comes to sports with the podcast here
i've been through [__] hell
with this [__] i don't want you guys to
start betting 300 a [__] game but if
you bet 10 like i tell people people hit
me up all the time joey we signed up for
draftkings how much do you recommend 10
bucks
10 bucks you're gonna pick up 18 19 50
that's better than nothing that's lunch
that's gas and guess what you lose 10
bucks
your kid still eats
it's that simple but when you're
gambling [__] ten thousand dollars
i'll tell you what
that's a different [__] world i don't
even have
i don't even have the patience to sit
there
like when i bet 25 i get a little angry
from time to time not all the time you
know but i look at it like how the [__]
did they lose like whenever you bet the
knicks
brooklyn nets forget it i don't bet home
games or ben against home [__] teams
but anyway
let's change it up a little bit wrap
this up in a different [__]
perspective here been a great week
i'm feeling [__] better every day i'm
looking better you know i'm sleeping
last night i had shitty [__] sleep
i kept dreaming i was for him off the
bed
that's [__] crazy
and i didn't get it's not like i ate an
edible or nothing i had a little [__]
reefer i had my little pill and i had
[__] uh
i take these [__] and i switch them
around every night to sleep i have the
uh cbd lion
gummies with melatonin [__]
tremendous but after two or three nights
i got to switch them up for a week
i took some of those last night
i take this [__] uh
vix whatever like nyquil without the
quilt
you know what i'm saying
whenever you want to [__] absolutely
want to sleep
nyquil will [__] you up trust me but you
mean you don't do nothing to me no more
like i could just drink it if i'm sick
and stuff but the nyquil without the
quill
it's not bad it's a little cherry
flavored you hit two shots of that [__]
smoke a little bong head after that you
get that little blackberry flavor in
your mouth and [__]
you get nice and [__] up you giggle a
little bit you go to [__] bed i watch
bobby flay and get hungry you know you
sit there and you're like bobby
what the [__] where am i and that's the
thing when you watch bobby flay yeah
when you watch bobby flay you get so
hungry but you're like man i could go
for that but all i got some peanut
butter and jelly upstairs i ain't got no
[__] uh
fall last night he made risotto
seafood risotto with [__] yellow
paella
he was on fire last night bobby flay
even though i don't like bobby flay that
much i think he's a [__] dick i
always [__] i always cheer for the
people that go up against bobby flay
against them but the game is [__]
fixed because they always give the
judges the second dish and they know
it's [__] bobby flay the united had
this cute little skinny cuban girl on
there she made a beautiful picadillo
with white [__] rice some yucca which
is a mistake never throw them with the
yuca white people like the fried bananas
you know what i'm saying that was the
mistake i was yelling at it through the
tv through osmosis switch that yuka up
yuca's like a potato but it smells like
[__] oh my god listen i'm as cuban as
can be
and i don't need [__] yuka and they
put garlic on it garlic sauce it looks
delicious but
not for uncle joey not not this [__]
time around
and here's bobby flay he made a yellow
rice with pot with uh picadillo number
one
piccadillo and yellow rice don't [__]
go together
that's rule number one if you're [__]
cuban
that's why you'll never see joey at that
[__] like there's these restaurants in
l.a well they just shot the dude in
beverly hills a couple months ago they
had two shootings out there
bella rose or whatever they had that
yellow rice they had great black beans
but they had yellow rice i can't go in
there no more i'm a [__] cuban you
know what i'm saying i can't put yellow
beans on [__] yellow rice like
rice-a-roni the [__] is wrong with these
people
so
it's the truth so what i [__] do is
i'm watching this
and she's got the perfect plate plus
she's cuban here's what pissed me the
[__] off two of the judges one dude was
a cuban owned the restaurant the other
chick was like on a committee of spanish
restaurants in new york city but she was
as cuban as to be
then there was a chinese dude guess what
the two cubans threw [__]
uh shade on her but the chinese dude
said it was the best meal i ever [__]
had i was furious i'm like this
[__] these two [__] cubans
they were like top shelf cubans you know
what i'm saying like you want to smack
them in the [__] head they just came
over like 30 years ago and they like
gloria stefan and [__] [__] them
[__] her and andy garcia you see him at
the super bowl sitting there like
let me tell you something la
is getting more and more [__]
disgusting
i don't know what's going on with people
anymore
that was not for me though that whole
i don't know guys i
i don't want to say nothing but like
i don't like anything in l.a because
people got to act like [__] they
showed antonio brown sitting next to
kanye west with a [__] mask on his
face like a [__] idiot
jennifer lopez with [__] big glasses
dancing meanwhile she [__] every other
guy in that [__] room ben affleck
the black dude is there piffy puffy
whatever his [__] name was
they're all there she [__] eight dudes
in the room she's over that [__]
dancing i'm like this j oh matt damon
with a [__] little [__] mustache like
walking around shaped the [__] him i
don't care if you're shooting the movie
shaped that [__] mustache you're not
the guy from [__] community you know
what i'm saying like
they all want to have that little [__]
mustache guys and then you had like mark
wahlberg on the phone
that's always a beauty and then you got
my man the rock that wrestled in [__]
after football he went to wwe
and he eats more steroids and [__]
attila the hun and he's out there
jumping up and down yelling and
screaming it just wasn't for [__] me
i gotta tell you something i always like
to rock i'm starting to hate that
[__] now he's such a [__]
disney [__] [__]
i can't
the dog these people are just sad now
anymore that's it you sell your soul
and for what
to go to the super bowl and then post i
came full circle get the [__] out of
here rock go talk to rogue and make up
with them you [__] sucker
anyway
i love you [__] with all my
heart thank you for watching
on a beautiful wednesday it's [__]
cold
but i always appreciate doing you
[__] i love
doing the podcast i like just talking
[__] and smoking dope again
i'm not ready for a [__] zoom yet
maybe next week we'll do a little zoom
and get some new blood in here you guys
don't want to look at me all the [__]
time i've got to tell you something guys
i'm looking at myself and i'm being
honest
i'm not looking good lately i don't care
what it people tell me you look younger
no yeah don't look uglier i look uglier
and [__] older i'm losing my hair i
got more [__] lost hair i'm getting
my face is turning gray can you believe
that [__] but hey i'm gonna be 59 i'm
gonna have a great weekend
and uh i'll touch base with you
[__] thursday yeah
50 [__] nine years old do i hate that
number with all my [__] heart
i hate that number with all my [__]
heart man
but you know what i really want to do
for my birthday this year
i'm going to go to jiu jitsu
on your birthday
yeah i want to do something that
the biggest mistake i ever made in my
life was on my birthday it was quitting
karate in 1979. that was close to
40 [__] years ago you know 42 years
ago 43 years ago
this year i want to go on i want to go
to karate i'm going to go to jiu jitsu
on my birthday and just i don't know
just to come full circle like the
[__] rock now
i don't know why
yeah
what the [__] are these people talking
about anymore anyway
i love you [__] with all my
heart thank you for always supporting me
i'm over here just talking [__] having a
good time but guess what [__] i'm
back
and that means it's gonna get [__]
interesting i love you [__]
with all my heart thank you for
supporting
and uh i'll see you monday morning the
21st tip
top [__] magoo love you [__]
and now
for a word from a [__] sponsor
jack
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening today we talked about some
football we talked about the [__]
rock but hey now it's time to talk about
my sponsors relief ban listen i've told
you a thousand times about my anxiety i
talk about it on the show
and that's why when i say relief ban
helps me with my anxiety you know it's
the real deal relief man has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
prevent anxiety-induced
nausea and vomiting it's like the name
says it's just a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea
caused by things like anxiety you change
the intensity of it depending on how
you're feeling to make it stronger or
weaker this
that
thing worked to me when i was with the
surgery from my knee listen i loved it i
remember i got this box in the mail and
i thought it was one of the doctors that
sent it to me and it was really my agent
that she sent me just to try and i was
so happy i wore it to my surgery and it
was tremendous and i felt great relief
banners 100 drug free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed and they just released the newest
model the relief man sport the sport is
waterproof has an extended battery life
and can even attach to your apple or
android watch so listen i know you got a
aunt an uncle a brother or sister
somebody who's going through chemo
listen or just anxiety or just to get
motion sickness relief band makes a
great gift at any time of the year so
give it a shot right now they got an
exclusive offer if you go to
reliefbend.com
and use promo code joey you receive
a 20 off plus free shipping and no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee who's better than you nobody
that's the best offer you'll find for
relief band anywhere but you have to use
my code so head over to
reliefband.com and use promo code joey
for 20 off and free shipping relief man
r e l i e f
b a and d dot com
go there right now use code joey and get
20 off free shipping and the 30-day no
questions asked guaranteed the joint is
also brought to you by cbd line in my
world
there's nothing better than cbd lion why
because that works i don't know what
they have in it
i've done 400 cbd bottles that haven't
done dick compared to cbd line the good
thing is it comes in a tincture capsules
cream melatonin
gummies go to
cbdline.com right now
read the third-party lab results and
you'll be as impressed as i am when you
want to order something go to the box
pressing code joey join a church and get
20 off delivered to your house it's that
simple
cbdlion.com i want to thank cbd lion i
want to thank relief band
i want to thank zip recruiter and i also
want to thank betterhelp.com
all services that can help you out and
they've helped me out so
knock yourself out
use code joey
and i love you [__] have a great
weekend stay black
and i'll be back monday morning the 21st
with some [__] great news and some
[__]
tremendous analogies have a great
weekend
shoot that poison arrow [__]
[Music]
so
you